[Music]
no I don't think they are no no we can't
do enough to protect our kids we got to
make sure that our kids are aware of the
threats on social media absolutely not
the Congress Black Hawk has been on this
now for at least 20 years well
absolutely not and I think Senator
Blackburn from the great state of
Tennessee my colleague is going to hold
their feet to the fire so I have seen
much of that I've had hearings of my own
but that's yet to be seen I'm sure
they'll send something out that will be
worthy to look at anyway we'll see what
they do to them it should be very
obvious about what you see in terms of
the content what's happening with youth
depression what's happening to youth
suicide and a lot of it's driven by
what's what they're getting access to in
the social media Tech CEOs have utterly
and completely failed to act at
adequately to protect Children online
and that's the reason why they've lost
trust they've completely squandered
their credibility and everyone agrees
Republicans and Democrats that we need
to move forward with rules and
safeguards for kids that are in the law
not relying on them to do the right
thing we have um a responsibility to
protect children of course but it starts
with parents the problem gets worse not
better well there's a lot more that we
can do to safeguard children on social
media if you look at the statistics and
actually the numbers on the mental
health issues caused by social media use
and The Addictive nature of that and the
predatory nature of what goes on online
there's a whole lot more big Tech to be
doing young children are being targeted
for advertising for indoctrination we
know you know one of their concerns with
uh Tik Tock for example is the influence
that communist China has uh so we need
to see more protections of our children
on the internet so they aren't targeted
uh in in ways that can hurt them
mentally emotionally or physically I
want to say Tik Tock band in the United
States for a start they have the ability
uh to adjust their um
algorithms to
prevent
advertising to children that targets
children especially preens who are
susceptible to uh criticism I don't
think we're never do enough to safeguard
our our children on social media right
um I think there's uh uh some
constitutional considerations here
between First Amendment uh rights uh
which need to be balanced with the fact
that uh a lot of these Technologies are
are putting misinformation out and
influencing um not just our kids but our
our constituents our voters in ways that
that frankly are um nefarious in some
cases right so uh we've got to make the
prote make sure the protections are in
place while still honoring the
Constitution